[Music]
low-res bicycles is a special everything
a special frame especially wheels a
special paint everything is special the
bicycles we make is make with love
because it's with our hands you know
those bikes snoop and countless other
rappers wrote around in you know the
ones that ooze that West Coast style
lowrider bikes low to the ground chromed
out gold-plated they're an extension of
lowrider car culture and they all
started here I am the Godfather of the
lowrider bicycles when I was 10 years is
to fix all the bytes of the neighbors
always dreamed with a motorcycle and a
car but since I was too small in no
money so I put my mine and bicycles a
mainstay in Compton in West Coast
culture these iconic bikes were actually
first created in Mexico I brought the
lowrider to California in early 80s and
soon after locals took notice of the
shiny swaggy rides hanging in a shop
when I started making bikes and put it
in a display people come and they say
can you make me one of those and then
they spread and now we have customers
from all over the world this is one of
the men's creators right here
I almost packed we put everything on
here blew my mind when you put it on
here for me it's a completely different
than the regular pike and the way they
look and the way they drive is art
people dream and we make the dream come
true
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oakland really will chew up and spit you
out like I guess nothing you know people
get killed every day you know living
although nothing is promised to you know
so if I'm going tomorrow what legacy
would I leave behind my name is Tyrone
Stevenson also known as baby champ
discovery bike King and I'm the founder
and the CEO of the original discovery
light team
all right because it's my lifestyle I
don't know it just makes me express
myself even more you work with youth
that lives in the community and teach
them how to make their bicycles for
students you know for kids to be a part
of the team you have to have at least a
2.0 GPA some of them like it some of
them don't but at the end of the day
they have to respect it if they want to
be a part of this team we use different
bike parts to make one big one and make
it look better back basically fix
anything on the bike now scary ride King
teaches you how to you know customize
their bikes put aluminum foil and duct
tape and spray paint on the bike and you
know make nice sky every bike is bigger
than his life a regular bike is just a
regular bike I ride a bike because I
like the way they look you get to show
it off and say you made it yourself
[Music]
yesterday was our grand opening of the
shed the first Youth brand bike shop
ever in Oakland I found it the original
stripper by team officially 2007 yeah my
cousin angry so bittersweet feelings to
open up the show you know just knowing
that my cousin Avery isn't around
you know just to see you know just to
have his presence here because it was
killed it wasn't murder senseless and
nothing to do with nothing I feel like
this whole movement is dedicated to him
you know and I do this because one day I
might not be here and somebody else
could step into my place and keep it
going
[Music]
the main thing people think about
Compton's you go into Compton and
everybody's gangbang you're not you can
shooting at you but it's really not like
that there have been times that people
made rude comments while we were at a
competition one of the girls had said oh
they're from Compton they probably have
bullet holes in their barn or something
- right for confident there comes a
sense of pride my name is Sheila ofso
I'm 17 years old and I'm a student at
the cottage near Posse a program that
keeps kids on horses and off the streets
looks great bend your knee though and
you see them make sure you supposed to
have your ear W children down GGO long
line I've been riding with the coffee
near Posse for about six years now I am
one of the more experienced riders in
the program I have learned a lot about
myself I definitely have more patience
after working with horses like when I
first started riding I like eleven years
old I just always get in trouble from
like attitude problems you come in with
the bad attitude when you're trying to
ride a horse and it comes out through
them - it's like you're in sync with
your horse
we are supposed to be insane it's a
partnership
we do have serious competitors at the
configure posse
we talked to a show per month just to
show what kind of progress that we've
been doing and we're kind of we're
continuing with the kids we're coming
out there and competing with the upper
level people I came in fourth for the
metal finals at the Interscholastic
equestrian League competition that's a
big deal it is a stereotype that more
people in the horse world are white and
rich but there are more people from
different backgrounds and different
demographics that are competing now it
was good to break the stereotype
[Music]
a great big story we're here mama we
made it
everybody say that is better my mom's
couldn't even do this they think me we
got our grandma's cooking for us
no this is us we did that right yeah
that's young man trap is is take risks
and prosper and that's what we do in
here so that's what we eat is trap
kitchen fixing shrimps in the bag trap
kitchen is this is a spot where you
prepare products to be distributed
underground we just use that mentality
with food we're a full-blown catering
service you also can order for delivery
during the week my team consists of
myself and three other guys I called my
brothers my boy AWOL
DJ keV and bad news we're a small team
but we get the job done all the time you
know I mean we always Crips and bloods
yeah I mean when that kind of stuff
of course I'm getting arrested every
other day for nothing a shooting at us
so now the only day we worried about is
some fool burnin up like all running out
that's it let's talk it to my mom you
got to do something I'm like okay well
what can I do
I've seen that record our blue
commercial on TV I'm like and I look
kind of cool I could probably do
something with that I know but you can
make good money cooking I'm motivated
started culinary school and that's where
I began to practice my craft you know
[Music]
he really came in here
I'm Vega de steel I broke what we gonna
do like we need some money I said wait
if we can sell some food through
Instagram I was like posting my food and
people was like oh that looks so good
that looks great and I like okay now
it's time for me to offer this food to
the streets like howdy boy pushes though
you know I'm saying and it worked
the key to our success we never gave up
man every day that's all I think about
is how can we improve our company how
can we improve our food how can we
improve the taste even though I'm
reading the house trapping I feel like
it's a real restaurant
[Music]
you
[Music]
there's a lot of places that don't let
me perform simply because I'm black
that doesn't really get to me because
I'm trying to show the world that you
know music is universal it can unite us
all my name is Ryan Lowry and I'm also
known as an attempt an arrow and
compañero simply means the black friend
I see original music Americana panda SIA
Daniel Norteno mariachi little I've been
around Hispanic so I mean it actually
comes natural in me it flows out I grew
up in the streets of Compton I lived in
a neighborhood that was predominantly
black and Mexican it's a wonderful thing
to say you know I came from Compton
because they say a lot of people don't
make it out I've traveled to a lot of
places and I'm all over TV and I can say
hey I'm from company
a lot of people tell me like hey you
were supposed to be Mexican God just
left in the oven too long I know for a
fact that I am african-american but yeah
I do feel like I live that light I have
lived a run gentle life I've had horses
I've had roosters goats eggs everything
I know how to saddle up a horse you
don't I make him dance and everything a
lot of people misunderstand and say hey
you're trying to be Mexican too much I'm
like wow there are American Cowboys
there are people who use boots and just
that's what I was taught what I've been
around but yes like I said in my song
but like I said in my song I have the
heart and soul of a Mexican and that I
think that that pretty much is what
counts
[Music]
you